[Musique]
la guerre froide entre les États-Unis et
l'Union soviétique entre le modèle
capitaliste et le modèle communiste en
est aussi passé par une lutte acharnée
sur le terrain de la propagande auprès
de la jeunesse en témoigne le
documentaire que nous venons de voir
réaliser par Joël Farges et c'est de
cette affrontement idéologique culturel
dont nous allons débattre maintenant
avec nos invités présents aujourd'hui
sur ce plateau de débat doc avec vous
pour commencer Fabrice dalmeda bienvenue
vous êtes historien vice-président de
l'université Paris 2 Panthéon Assas vous
êtes un spécialiste de la propagande de
la communication par l'image et de
l'histoire des médias votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule l'histoire mondiale
des riches publiée chez plomb un livre
enquête qui nous révèle l'origine des
plus grandes dynasties financières on
citera aussi en ce qui vous concerne une
histoire mondiale de la propagande de
1900 à nos jours publié voilà maintenant
quelques temps aux éditions de la
Martinière Cécile vessier est avec nous
bienvenue et vous êtes professeur en
études russes et soviétique à
l'université Rennes 2 et auteur entre
autres de la fabrique de l'homme nouveau
après Staline les arts et la culture
dans le projet soviétique publié au
presse universitaire de Rennes on va
préciser que c'est un ouvrage collectif
que vous avez dirigé mode que ça est
également avec nous bienvenue et vous
êtes directrice du domaine
eure-atlantique à l'Institut de
recherche stratégique de l'école
militaire on vous doit entre autres
guerres de l'information et stratégie
d'influence propagande et diplomatie
publique des États-Unis depuis la guerre
froide également disponible au presse
universitaire de Rennes j'ai retenu
cette phrase Fabrice d'Almeida c'est
Eric
qui dirigeait alors la jeunesse
pionnière en RDA on l'a vu dans ce
documentaire c'est en 1948 qui contrôle
la jeunesse contrôle l'avenir disait-il
c'est de s'embêter une des clés qui
valait pour les deux camps cette guerre
froide qu'est-ce qu'il faut en garder de
ce film que nous venons de voir
concernant cette fameuse guerre
culturelle que ce sont livrées les deux
grandes puissances de cette époque à
quel point les cerveaux des enfants ont
été retirés à leurs parents parce que si
on regarde ça dans la très longue
histoire depuis le Moyen-âge l'époque
moderne le 19e siècle encore ceux qui
façonnaient l'imaginaire des enfants
c'était les familles on racontait des
histoires en famille il y avait la
veillée voilà ce qu'on voilà ce qui
était les cadres et à partir de la fin
du 19e siècle avec les grands médias
avec le cinéma qui va venir puis la
radio puis la télévision toute cette
industrie qu'on avait dans ce film et
ben il y a des grands groupes des
grandes puissances et des États qui vont
essayer de s'emparer de la tête de nos
enfants il y avait une machine
propagandise peut-être plus forte que
l'autre à la sortie de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale c'était peut-être les
États-Unis ce qu'on peut dire les choses
comme ça ou pas alors c'est pas les
mêmes méthodes et c'est pas le même
degré de contraintes faut pas oublier
qu'en Union soviétique
il y a pas de pluralisme médiatique
c'était déjà le cas dans
l'entre-deux-guerres il y a pas de
possibilité d'écouter les médias
étrangers c'était déjà le cas dans
l'entre-deux-guerres il y a une pression
très forte avec des arrestations de
masse mais ça je pense que Cécile va en
parler mieux que moi donc le système de
propagande et est absolu en Union
soviétique il est relatif aux États-Unis
d'ailleurs les Américains très vite
après la guerre disent le concept de
propagande va pas chez nous il faut
plutôt parler de persuasion pourquoi
parce qu'il y a de la concurrence entre
différents opinions politiques donc on
n'est pas dans la propagande on est
plutôt dans la persuasion les sons de
mode propagande pour les États
autoritaires et totalitaires il y a un
mot qui est beaucoup utilisé aussi c'est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'est soft powers
un anglicisme c'est la puissance 12
c'est-à-dire affronter quelqu'un sans
sans brutalité
c'est aussi l'histoire de l'évolution du
soft power américain qu'on a vu dans ce
film non c'est ça et c'est même ce qu'on
appelait le complexe
Hollywood militaro industriel et dès les
années 60 il y a des savants américains
notamment pour pour signaler la grande
collusion entre le monde du cinéma le
monde des armées et le monde des
publicitaires qui fait le passage entre
les deux puisque ce sont les grandes
agences qui façonnent les messages que
les médias doivent ensuite transmettent
donc effectivement on parle de ça mais
ce qui est très intéressant dans le soft
power c'est que c'est la question de
l'exportation et ce qui est amusant
c'est qu'en France ceux qui vont
recevoir les westerns américains qui
étaient censés faire la propagande
pro-américaine et bien figurez-vous que
ce sont notamment les communistes les
communistes regardent les films
américains dans les années 50 dans la
région de Longwy dans le nord de la
France et qu'est-ce qu'ils voient eux
des gens qui luttent contre l'injustice
capitaliste et résultat ils vont
diffuser les westerns américains John
Wayne va servir même à faire de la
propagande communiste il faut quand même
le faire avant de voir ce qui se passait
du côté soviétique on va passer un
premier extrait du documentaire c'est un
dessin animé c'est une production
soviétique
à Moscou les studios Soyouz film sont au
contraire radicaux
il représente les États-Unis comme une
gomme or gangrenée par le dollar et le
racisme
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il faut en garder de ce
qu'on vient de voir c'est la manière
dont décrivait donc les Soviétiques
les méchants américains le méchant
capitaliste il y a un fond musical qui
est le jazz c'est pas tout à fait neutre
aussi non c'est à dire je crois d'abord
les images sont ravissantes il y a quand
même ça c'est à dire que c'est d'une
violence folle c'est pas d'une
originalité parce qu'on a ça sur toute
la période voire encore maintenant où on
a des rôles très soviétiques mais les
images sont ravissantes et il y a de la
créativité et j'irai il y a quand même
deux choses sur lesquelles il faut
vraiment insister c'est à dire que en
Union soviétique contrairement le savent
power c'est quelque chose où on veut
vous donner envie de regarder pourquoi
ça a marché Walt Disney pourquoi ça a
marché les westerns c'est qu'au bout du
compte les gens avaient envie de
regarder et alors que en Union
soviétique il y avait ce que vous venez
de dire c'est à dire d'une part une
exclusion d'à peu près tout le reste et
puis il y avait une machine de
propagande qui impliquait les
organisations de jeunesse avec
obligation de faire partie de ces
organisations de jeunesse qui qui est le
même discours organisé vraiment comme
une campagne de publicité à partir de
des centres de propagande du comité
central qui ensuite été répercuté sur la
jeunesse c'est à dire qu'il y avait tout
un ensemble et je dirais à l'inverse
comme on interdisait par exemple on a
longtemps interdit le jazz le pas
toujours parce qu'après ils ont compris
un peu leurs problèmes le finalement
vous savez comme moi que ce qui fait
envie c'est justement ce qui est
interdit ce qu'on a justement envie de
regarder de connaître de voir c'est ce
qui interdit c'est-à-dire que quand
l'Union soviétique s'est écroulée quels
étaient les films qui triompher dans les
années 90 c'est les chartes negger et
c'était les Stallone pourquoi parce que
ça avait été interdit pendant des
décennies donc les gens voulaient le
voir donc au bout du compte cette ces
interdictions qui n'existaient pas dans
le monde capitaliste on pouvait voir des
films soviétiques on pouvait écouter les
cœurs de l'Armée Rouge ont généré des
envies folles en Union soviétique
surtout à partir de la mort de Staline
ou se diffuser des livres étrangers en
sa mise date où on échangeait des
disques pour un mois de salaire je veux
dire ça s'acheter un mois de salaire les
disques de rock donc finalement ça
générer des envies et d'une certaine
manière on peut dire que c'est le monde
capitaliste qui a remporté la guerre
froide culturelle on parlait du soft
power qui évidemment
doit se diriger vers l'extérieur de ses
frontières c'était pas vraiment un soft
power soviétique c'était plutôt destiné
à au bloc de l'Est d'une manière
générale cette propagande culturelle ou
elle disait à déstabiliser l'Ouest et de
quelle manière en fait il y avait
plusieurs choses c'est-à-dire que il y
avait la propagande pour former et
c'était explicite formé un homme
soviétique en Union soviétique et c'est
absolument explicite Lénine a été le
premier à le dire on va se servir de la
culture pour faire un homme soviétique
qui pourra construire le communisme et
qui sera à la fois le moyen de la
construction du optimisme et le résultat
il y avait ensuite exportation vers les
pays du
globe soviétique pour les former de la
même façon donc il y avait d'un côté on
exportait par exemple des romans pour
enfants et on a exporté ils ont exporté
les purges aussi ils ont exporté l'écran
procès le et il y avait et ça des 17 18
il y avait aussi exportation et là il y
a quelque chose à mon avis d'ailleurs
qui manque dans le dans le dans le film
c'est à dire toutes les actions qui ont
été menées par le communitaire dans
avant la guerre et qui consistait je
pense par exemple à des gens comme
villeminson Berg qui est qui a vécu en
France qui est mort d'ailleurs qui a été
tué en France sans doute qui a commencé
en exportant des films soviétiques et
les communistes ou pro communistes allez
voir et en plus des chefs quand ils
allaient voir les films Dyson Stein il y
avait de quoi pleurer alors c'était
complètement faux par rapport à la
réalité historique mais c'était une
forme de soft power mais différente
les États-Unis il y a plusieurs choses
qui sont mises en avant et notamment
Walt Disney dans ce film on va voir là
aussi un extrait du du documentaire
c'est krokchef c'est en 59 première
visite d'un numéro un soviétique aux
États-Unis et il souhaite aller voir le
parc Walt Disney en Floride regardez
cette extrême
le 15 septembre 509 cruchef arrive aux
États-Unis c'est le premier voyage
officiel d'un leader communiste
coup de chef a fait savoir qu'il
souhaitait visiter Disneyland mais
Disney lui en refuse l'entrée au motif
que ses films sont interdits en URSS
[Musique]
des envies susciter des envies du côté
soviétique semble-t-il le cas pour coup
de chef en 59 on lui refuse l'entrée de
ce parc de Walt Disney Walt Disney c'est
un symbole de lentilles communisme c'est
comme ça qu'il faut traduire ce qu'on a
vu dans ce documentaire concernant ce
mastodonte de l'industrie du dessin
animé américain un petit peu le propos
et l'usage qui est fait de Walt Disney
d'abord par rapport aux propos qu'on a
tenus entre soft power et propagande le
soft power c'est c'est un concept qui
est né dans les années 90 c'est Joseph
Nike qui le rend public dans les années
90 donc l'utiliser pour la période de
guerre froide c'est à la fois juste un
peu anachronique et en plus ça se
comprend en contexte américain peut-être
un peu plus en largement on peut moins
l'attribuer aussi
à l'adversaire je dirais concernant la
visite de khrouchev de 59 il y a eu un
[Musique]
des blocs de l'Est qui la Roumanie où
était diffusé dans les
ambassades des films qui avaient pour
but d'aculturer un petit peu les
populations de l'Est à la culture
américaine mais ces films étaient
d'abord prévisionnés par le ministre de
la culture de l'époque et en Roumanie
quand on montrait un film américain ou
on avait sur le parking d'une
d'une manufacture ou d'une d'une zone
industrielle les voitures des ouvriers
le ministre de la Culture roumain se
levait en disant en propagande et donc
interdiction de diffuser ce film un
public plus large que celui qui était
présent dans l'ambassade américaine de
l'époque donc c'est pour vous donner une
idée un petit peu du fait de cette
enfermement puisqu'on était dans les
murs de l'information à l'époque et
c'est ça que traduit aussi cette
anecdote pas simplement le fait que
Disney allait être le premier rempart
peut être le premier porteur de la du
soft power américain et aussi un rempart
donc c'est un acteur privé qui fait
partie du soft powers n'est pas un
acteur gouvernemental et les acteurs
gouvernementaux américains peut-être que
on l'a passé en sous-tex dans le
documentaire sont extrêmement organisés
le premier être organisé et organiser
une propagande d'État de la part des
États-Unis c'est alzhenhower qui reprend
les commandes donc des États-Unis au
début des années 50 il dit tout de suite
si l'on veut mener une guerre froide et
une guerre froide culturelle à ce
moment-là donnons-nous les moyens et
créons une agence d'information des
États-Unis qui n'est pas la CIA ceinture
Intelligence Agency qui ne fait pas du
renseignement et qui a pour but de faire
de l'information et de travailler main
dans la main avec un certain nombre de
studios pas simplement Disney pour
produire des films à destination des
publics étrangers donc il s'agit pas de
propagande au sens américain du terme
puisque c'est pas pour les publics
américains mais c'est pour les
populations du bloc de l'Ouest et du
bloc de et puis cette guerre froide aura
reçu des répercussions à l'intérieur
même des États-Unis en réactivant
notamment la commission d'enquête sur
les activités anti-américaines qui
avaient été mises en place avant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale mais réactiver
notamment au tout début des années 50
entre 50 et 54 avec le fameux sénateur
McCarthy chasse aux sorcières parce que
il s'agissait de déterminer ce qui était
communiste et anticommuniste finalement
notamment
à Hollywood et dans la société
américaine là il y a eu vraiment une
purge on peut appeler les choses comme
ça absolument ça devient une faille en
fait dans le système américain puisque
on a l'impression qu'il y a une censure
enfin c'est pas on a l'impression il y a
une censure et ça donne une résonance
toute particulière avec notre actualité
contemporaine de taxer certaines
activités d'anti-américaines d'être à la
solde des agents de l'étranger alors là
en l'occurrence pour les années 50 54 on
parle d'activités qui sont communistes
mais qui ont une résonance pas
simplement sur le territoire américain
mais dans toute capable de l'Ouest et le
blog de l'Est puisque là l'ennemi en
l'occurrence donc le rival soviétique
peut s'emparer de ce narratif pour dire
regarder ce que font les Américains et
c'est purge que l'on voit aux États-Unis
ont aussi lieu dans un certain nombre de
centres culturels et d'ambassade
américaine qui sont en poste ou
positionnés dans tout bloc de l'Est et
donc c'est une très mauvaise image que
les Américains envoient à ce moment-là
juste dans cette période 55
on va dire épurée
d'une certaine manière cette cette
fameuse commission McCarthy parce que la
déferlante de la production
hollywoodienne
commence avec le plan Marshall qui
permettra la diffusion des œuvres
américaines en Europe de l'Ouest
notamment qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
ça fonctionne moyennement en réalité
parce qu'il y a très peu d'acteurs qui
vont être la cristée très peu de
producteurs qui ont de la cristée et au
le système au hollywoodien continue à
fonctionner j'allais dire avec les mêmes
recettes les mêmes mécanismes et les
mêmes genres il y aura peut-être un
petit peu plus de films noirs dans la
deuxième moitié des années des années 50
mais bon ça n'empêche pas les Billy
Wilders de continuer à avoir une vision
qui est très humaniste
donc c'est pas je crois pas que c'est
que ça que ça change en profondeur en
revanche ça bouge quand même diffuser le
fameux américain waofly oui mais c'était
déjà le cas avant ça continue après je
veux dire enfin c'est dès les années 30
enfin dès les années même 20 le cinéma
américain est l'un des premiers exportés
mondialement et l'une des premières
importations aussi bien en France qu'en
Allemagne je dis ça parce que aussi bien
le dans l'Allemagne dans la France et
dans l'Allemagne des années 30 on
regarde aussi les films américains on a
tendance à l'oublier mais c'est déjà le
cas donc je crois pas que c'est ça le
gouvernement clé ce qui me frappe
beaucoup plus de ce point de vue c'est
que vu côté français nous dès 1949 on a
pris une loi de protection des
publications pour la jeunesse ce qui
fait qu'on on importe pas autant de
Mickey qu'on pourrait on importe pas
toutes les tous les comics par exemple
américains sont classés en bande
dessinée pour adulte ils sont pas
destinés aux enfants et en revanche ça
va permettre à la BD belge de venir chez
nous les Jacobs et Mortimer les Tintins
tout ça va arriver et si pilotes est au
départ un magazine belge en réalité
c'est parce que on continue d'être dans
cette même loi sur les publications pour
la jeunesse de 1949 et ça change tout
parce que ça fait qu'on va avoir des
j'allais dire nos super-héros des
éditions vaillants qui sont mentionnées
dans le documentaire par exemple c'est
voilà il y a pig gadget il y a le
grelesset 13 le résistant français il y
a l'Indien il y a Rahan le fils des
chaises des achats rouges donc vous
voyez ce que je veux dire on a d'autres
d'autres figures qui vont émerger et qui
font qu'on a un imaginaire peut-être un
petit peu différent de celui des
Britanniques de celui des Belges qui
recevait ses publications ou de celui
des Italiens qui avaient eux leurs
propres leurs propres bandes dessinées
et qui ont fait émerger des figures
comme Corto Maltes de gopra donc c'est
intéressant en fait c'est une histoire
très très complexe de documentaire donne
la chronologie mais à l'intérieur il y a
plein de pulsions alors vous souhaitez
je vous donne la parole un tout petit
peu quand même sur ces
c'est purge de ma karting parce que je
pense qu'en France on a une vision
absolument faussée de cette chose-là
notamment parce que d'ailleurs ça a été
présenté en France par un certain nombre
je dirais d'acteurs culturels
liés à l'Union soviétique liée aux
parties communistes le c'est une page
qui est très laide dans l'histoire
américaine incontestablement
c'est-à-dire les aveux des yakazance je
dirais les interrogatoires étaient je
dirais c'est c'est une médiocrité
absolue c'est obligera Bertol Bretch
Charlie Chaplin alors Sunways les
États-Unis la seule chose qu'on oublie
toujours de dire on oublie deux choses
et y compris d'ailleurs dans le film
qu'on vient de voir on oublie de dire
que oui il y avait une vraie
infiltration de l'Union so du comité
terme en Hollywood et il y a eu à cette
période à partir je dirais de la guerre
d'Espagne où ils ont envoyé alors je
peux juste vous donner un nom parce
qu'il y a des travaux sur lui c'est Auto
4 ce qui travaillait justement avec
médecin Berg qui a été envoyé à
Hollywood avec un certain nombre de
productions notamment sur la guerre
d'Espagne pour infiltrer le milieu des
gens qui étaient pour la guerre était
pour les républicains espagnoles et
ensuite été contre les nazis donc il y
avait des tout à fait bonne motivation
mais le milieu hollywoodien à cette
période et par la suite j'irai par
d'autres personnes a été réellement
infiltrée par des agents soviétiques il
y a eu ces réactions qui effectivement
sont épouvantables et voyez le
documentaire nous montre alors voilà il
y a la purge de ma cartouche donc on
parle de purge mais les purges en Union
soviétique c'est quand ton fusil les
gens quand on les déporte là je dirais
c'était pas c'était pas joli joli il y a
eu des c'est vrai il y a eu des qui ont
pas pu travailler qui ont mais c'était
d'un autre ordre et puis on vous dit et
puis regardez en Tchécoslovaquie les
opposants sont jugés et on vous montre
les photos les images d'un procès et il
se trouve qu'à ce procès il y avait ce
même Auto 4 le il y avait ce même Auto 4
qui était jugé pas du tout comme
opposant qui était jugé avec des
dirigeants communistes et ils ont tous
été exécutés donc c'est-à-dire que on
parle pas du tout du tout des mêmes
choses et de la même de la même ampleur
des mêmes conséquences
je suis absolument d'accord avec votre
point et en complément je dirais que les
Américains se sont auto corrigés d'abord
le point que vous vous rappeliez c'est
sylvestis ça fait écho aussi à toute
cette période du Congrès pour la liberté
de la culture et puis de cet ouvrage qui
a été qui avait eu un peu déco au
tournant des années 90 2000 qui est de
Francis under sur la CIA et c'est cette
lutte en fait cette vraie véritable
guerre culturelle des intellectuels pas
simplement des réalisateurs de films ou
des ou des auteurs mais pour en revenir
à l'autocorrection des Américains
puisque on a une progression
chronologique aussi dans le film on
parle des années 50-54 mais après on
passe aux années 60 et osé 60 donc on a
la figure de Kennedy et puis on a
surtout son premier agent de la
diplomatie publique et de la diplomatie
culturelle qui est edmero Edouard Moreau
qui est une figure du journaliste
américain et qui a combattu ma carte lui
il a été dans le mouvement inverse des
de ce qu'on a pu appeler les Red pour
être plus précis sur les termes si il
est beaucoup question des super-héros
à l'occasion de cette cette guerre
froide culturelle dont on parle là
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire des
super-héros américains comment
s'insert-il dans ce cet affrontement
culturel auquel on assiste durant la
Guerre Froide alors c'est une discussion
net qu'on a peut-être eu un petit peu
avant l'émission sur les super-héros
finalement les super-héros de la guerre
froide qui sont soutenus par les
productions par les la propagande
américaine c'est un les représentants
politiques je viens de parler de Kennedy
c'en est un au moment de la période
Kennedy l'agence d'information des
États-Unis commande des films et
notamment au moment de du de après
l'assassinat de Kennedy des films qui
sont à destination des publics étrangers
et qui ont pour but de montrer aussi de
valoriser le mythe le héros et je pense
que la présidence Kennedy en est une
illustration absolument archétypique il
y a des
l'idée qui sont faites pour l'Europe de
l'Ouest et l'Europe de l'Est plus sa
destination des adultes que des enfants
des films des films de propagande des
films de commande il y en a un grand
nombre donc le premier héros c'est le
président américain ensuite il y a ceux
des comics mais comment on le disait
tout à l'heure les comics c'est pas
forcément à destination des enfants en
plus le comics il a plutôt une vocation
aussi de d'anticipation de montrer en
fait ce que les Américains pourraient
faire plus de ça s'inscrit plutôt dans
une course à la technologie à sur fond
de course à l'espace à l'époque qui est
quand même toujours d'actualité et ça ça
nous ramène aux années 60 par exemple
dernière étape très importante du héros
américain c'est plutôt le héros des
films qui se passe sous le manteau et
plutôt au tournant la fin des années 70
début des années 80 quand il y a des
cassettes vidéos puisque c'est l'époque
et c'est plutôt les les Rocky Balboa
auxquels vous faisiez allusion qui se
passe sous le manteau au marché noir à
des prix à des prix d'or dans tous les
pays du bloc de l'Est et c'est ce sont
eux les héros de la guerre froide
vraiment qui sont là on est en plein
époque riganne absolument
intéressant d'un point de vue médiatique
dont on parle c'est une importance à un
impact auprès des populations
c'est que nous on a tendance à les
traiter aujourd'hui comme à destination
des enfants mais faut quand même
rappeler qu'une bonne partie des comics
et des personnages comme Superman
paraissent en strip donc il paraissent
dans de la presse du soir donc dans des
quotidiens américains
donc en fait il vise pas forcément à
l'époque aussi nettement les enfants les
adolescents que ça a été le cas après
les années 70-80 et puis deuxième chose
moi qui me frappe c'est la manière dont
chacun des systèmes organise son comment
dirais-je son environnement pour ces
films d'animation dont on a parlé à
l'Est qui a d'énormes mouvements parce
que si on veut reconnaître l'Est et
l'Ouest dans les années 50 et 60 l'Est
il passe leur temps à parler de la paix
donc dès qu'on voit une association il y
a écrit paix c'est un truc communiste
voilà bon et puis à l'Ouest c'est
culturel dès qu'il y a écrit institut
pour la culture ah ça c'est à l'ouest
généralement avec un petit soutien de la
CIA donc cette opposition là elle
débouche sur des des formations un peu
différentes par exemple les communistes
vont organiser des des festivaux des
festivals mondiaux de la jeunesse ils
vont organiser des camps de scouts qui
vont être des pionniers qui vont aller
recruter dans tous les pays on a oublié
ça met encore dans les années 80 les
pionniers et soviétiques prenaient des
dirigeants de parties travaillistes
britanniques de fils de du parti
gaudiste français de membres du de l'ANC
de Mandela d'Afrique du Sud qui
n'étaient pas encore au pouvoir et on
les emmenait tous à peu près 2000 par an
pour se retrouver pour créer une espèce
d'élite mondiale et côté anglo-saxon on
avait des mouvements internationaux
mouvements de jeunesse comme les scouts
par exemple qui devaient diffuser une
certaine conception du monde donc tous
ces dessins animés en réalité ce qui est
intéressant c'est de se dire qu'ils sont
enracinés socialement et y compris les
comics il y a cette espèce de de terreau
social qui doit travailler le cerveau de
nos franchement je suis désolé d'y
revenir alors et on parlait des des
années 60 il y a un élément important
qui est souligné bien sûr dans ce
documentaire c'est l'arrivée de la télé
dans les foyers américains pour
commencer il arrivera ensuite dans les
foyers à la fois aussi du côté de
l'ouest évidemment j'imagine du côté
soviétique qu'est-ce que ça a changé
dans la production culturelle et dans
cette propagande culturelle dont on
parle c'est arrivé de la télé dans les
foyers pour nous ça change tout il faut
quand même le dire parce que
auparavant le cinéma il y a une
inégalité absolue entre les États-Unis
et l'Union soviétique ou le bloc de
l'Est le cinéma américain est massif le
cinéma français marche très bien on a
très peu de films qui viennent de l'Est
il y en a quelques-uns qui arrivent au
Festival de Cannes il faut écouter les
critiques qu'il y avait à l'époque à la
radio sur Europe 1 sur France Inter ce
qu'on disait des films communistes
parfois il y avait de l'exaltation il y
avait beaucoup de critiques des systèmes
communistes et la télé est toujours oui
ça change tout parce que tout d'un coup
les fameux dessin animé qui se
finissaient par ces mots Cognets check
russe voilà ils arrivent chez nous ils
arrivent chez nous et en même temps on
voit à la télé arriver les Tex Avery qui
étaient des dessins animés fait à partir
des années 30 extrêmement violents
extrême mais qui nous déchire de rire
faut quand même le dire et on va pas
avoir tellement de Mickey à la télé
Mickaël à la télé en France c'est plus
tard donc pour la première fois les
petits-enfants français se retrouvent
avec de Gaulle qui développent la
télévision et qui à la fin du du De
Gaulle dans les années 60 afin 1969 on
est à 74 75 % d'équipement des ménages
en termes de télévision donc ça veut
dire que les trois quarts des Français
ont la télé donc les petits Français ont
des jours le jeudi après-midi c'était où
il y a tous ces dessins animés qui
s'affrontent et je trouve que ça fait de
notre pays un truc très particulier
parce que à la fois on a ce goût de
l'animation les petites poupées qui se
déplacent tous tout ce jeu voilà et et
le dessin animé pur américain et malgré
tout on est tous devenus addict plus au
dessin animé américain qu'au dessin
animé du blog de l'Est et ça pour moi
c'est un peu une énigme c'est vrai ce
que vous dites mais en même temps il y a
quand même une grosse différence c'est à
dire que le
il y a ces dessins animés tchécoslovaque
qui sont des petites merveilles
du dessin animé il y a une école
tchécoslovaque du livre pour enfants et
effectivement c'est plein de poésies il
n'y a pas de politique il n'y a
quasiment pas de politique c'est du rêve
c'est de la poésie c'est du c'est du
dessin le quand on voit que comme ça
mais je sais pas si
c'était extrêmement intéressant non non
non non non non non parce qu'ils disent
il y avait des choses il y avait la même
chose en Union soviétique qui était
produite pour l'Occident et pas pour les
populations locales et en fait on se
rend compte justement de la différence
culturelle aussi et ça c'est important
qu'il pouvait y avoir d'un pays à
l'autre il y a des pratiques qui sont
très similaires dans le blog de l'Est
les pratiques qui sont très similaires
c'est l'espèce de façon de tout coiffer
de tout organiser etc mais ça se produit
dans des contextes quand même différents
sur des fonds culturels différents et on
a ces petites merveilles tchécoslovaques
sur les télévisions françaises on ne
passait pas je n'en ai pas le souvenir
de dessin animé
soviétique pourquoi je veux dire sauf
après quand il y a eu winderstein qui
est un immense créateur je dirais avec
son son hérisson là dans le dans le
brouillard le lui c'est un immense
créateur mais ça vient plus tard et
sinon on ne passait pas de dessin animé
parce qu'ils étaient systématiquement
politique même quand c'était l'histoire
je dirais d'un petit cochon qui etc il y
avait un sous-entendu politique donc oui
on a connu la culture tchécoslovaque on
a connu des éléments mais on peut pas
dire que c'était un affrontement estos
c'était
on était un terrain esthétique mais
juste d'un mot
ça va retarder la création de l'école
française de films d'animation qui va
démarrer en fait à partir des années 80
et en fait dans ces années là on a René
Laloux qui va faire la planète sauvage
avec Ronan Topor film que j'évoque avec
une un certain plaisir et puis on aura
quoi on aura le Roi et l'Oiseau de
Grimaud en animation mais c'est très peu
quand on réfléchit et c'est après que ça
va venir
justement parce que les années 4 ans
c'est une période charnière qui aussi a
sorti de moyens techniques parce que si
les Américains prennent un ascendant
culturel dans la diffusion des images
dans la diffusion de l'information et de
l'entertainment parce que ce qu'on a pas
évoqué comme mot qui peut-être très ce
qui est un anglicisme mais qui veut dire
ce que ça veut dire c'est que finalement
la force des États-Unis sur toute cette
période de guerre froide c'est de
développer une diplomatie de
l'entertainment donc finalement des
images et des narratifs qu'ils soient
par le biais d'émissions de télévision
qui deviennent des émissions de
divertissement comme on dit aujourd'hui
et c'est dans les au début des années 80
que cela a cours ou bien de des films
d'animation que il crée cette séduction
là il le crée grâce à une révolution qui
est une révolution qui est celle de
l'information des moyens techniques le
satellite en particulier qui arrive dans
les années 80 et qui est un outil une
arme extraordinaire encore plus
puissante que la radio pour passer de
l'autre côté du rideau de fer et
pénétrer les foyers de l'Est et ça c'est
un avantage fort donc c'est il y a aussi
il y a le ce qu'on produit et ce qui est
attractif mais aussi il y a la capacité
à le diffuser et c'est sur cet avantage
là que les que les Américains mise au
début des années 80 mais je crois que
les Américains aussi avaient un sens
justement de ce qui plaisait c'est à
dire on peut appeler ça du marketing on
peut appeler ça le sens du spectacle
alors que les Soviétiques ils étaient
pris il y avait des des artistes
absolument talentueux mais ils étaient
toujours coincés par leur idéologie je
vais vous donner un exemple actuellement
en Russie on célèbre le centième
anniversaire d'un cinéaste qui s'appelle
Léonie de Guy day que tous les
Soviétiques exoviétiques et post
soviétiques adorent qui a fait qui a
fait des millions d'entrées en Union
soviétique qui a fait hurler de rire et
qui fait toujours hurler de rire bon
c'est en gros Gérard Oury si vous voulez
Gérard Oury à la sauce soviétique et en
fait ce guide n'a jamais été exporté en
Occident en plus les intellectuels
français féministe considéré que ça
c'était pour le peuple donc ça les
intéresse pas du tout donc il y avait
pas ce sentiment de il faut exporter
pour montrer que regardez comment on est
drôle regardez comme on va vous faire
rire ça sera le mot de la fin c'est trop
court évidemment on vous aurez garder
avec nous là encore un petit moment pour
parler c'est un sujet après ce film une
guerre froide très animée qu'on a
découvert dans ce débat doc et puis un
grand merci à tous les trois pour cet
échange que nous avons eu vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur
Twitter merci à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission j'ai moi je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]